Stanford University electronic circuits
is the bread and butter of Electrical
Engineering and it has been for a long
time so you might be forgiven if you
think that this kind of stale that is
sort of old-fashioned but it's not it
really is changing dramatically and the
reason why it's changing is that the
internet'll thinks it's driving new
circuit design hello I'm ooh laughs all
right and I'm here to tell you about
educational opportunities in the rapidly
changing field of electronic circuits
the circuits that Electrical Engineering
is design and fabricate test and verify
are the heart and soul of the Internet
of Things me have a new concept in
electrical engineering or embedded
systems we are embedding electronics in
everything you do in order to make you
more productive make you healthier make
you entertained everywhere you are
connected everywhere you are the courses
that you're going to be learning about
in this program gives you the
fundamentals of electronic circuit on
the digital side you're going to look at
CMOS digital circuits on the analog side
you will be learning about advanced
analog circuits in modern technology you
can have quite a bit of flexibility but
in the program to go in the digital
direction or an analog direction or
mixed signal direction and maybe also in
a very exciting field of sort of
low-power
distributed circuits if you work in a
company that has as part of their
business plan to be involved in Internet
of Things we reasonably want to take
this certificate so that you can be more
productive and also more visionary about
what you do
you